[Musik]
an so einem tag nach den beschlüssen von
bundesregierung und ministerpräsidenten
der länder und deren erklärungen spricht
man am besten mit denen die nicht dabei
waren und nicht entscheiden durften und
doch was zu sagen haben im land na dann
schönen guten tag kinogruppe
bundessprecher also bundesvorsitzender
der alternative für deutschland der
größten oppositionspartei im deutschen
bundestag immer intakt grüße sie herr
krupp an die bürger einzusperren ist
keine lösung haben sie gesagt mitte
dezember
da müssten sie ja nun ordentlich sauber
sein über die beschlüsse von gestern
oder haben sie ihre meinung geändert
unsere meinung kommt mir nicht geändert
und wir sind natürlich dementsprechend
sauer
zum einen über das vorgehen der
bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten was wieder einmal
gezeigt hat dass im stillen kämmerchen
das ausgegoren wurde dass auch die
parlamentarier wieder vor vollendete
tatsachen gestellt ist wieder wurde der
bundestag nicht vorab mit einbezogen das
kritisieren wir als erstes und wir sehen
natürlich auch anhand der maßnahme jetzt
ergriffen wurden will dass die
bundesregierung ihr versagen auch was
die im strategie angeht hier kaschieren
möchte und das kritisieren wir welche
maßnahmen hätten sie sich denn gewünscht
wir haben ja gesehen dass der harte
lockdown jetzt über weit über die
weihnachtsfeiertage auch im dezember
erfolg ist bisher nichts gebracht hat
auch in den incident zahlen als nichts
gebracht und daran erkennt man
eigentlich dass die unwirksamkeit hier
weiterhin vor herrscht wir haben hätten
uns weiter gewünscht vor allen in den
sommermonaten wie man wirklich von der
bundesregierung offenen landesregierung
hier in sachsen verpennt hat dass man
die risikogruppen also auch die hotspot
die ja in den alten und pflegeheim
vorherrschen in den krankenhäusern dass
man die besser schützt dass man endlich
hier auch mit personal nachrüstet das
ist ja das hauptproblem
und das hat man verschlafen und deswegen
will man jetzt versucht man jetzt mit
weiteren noch härteren maßnahmen hier
gegenzusteuern was wir absolut
unverhältnismäßig finden und auch
weiterhin großen schaden auch für die
volkswirtschaft erzeugen wird da bleiben
wir doch mal bei den einzelnen punkten
die sie ja schon angesprochen haben den
sie haben den schutz von risikogruppen
ja schon länger gefordert jetzt hat ja
die bundesregierung gestern noch einmal
den schutz von heimen intensiviert oder
will ihn intensivieren und dort
verpflichtende tests die gibt es ja
schon mehrmals pro woche
die offenbar nicht durchgeführt werden
in heimen oder nicht so intensiv will
die bundesregierung jetzt durch
freiwillige nochmal unterstützen und da
gibt es wohl auch schon zu sagen das
müsst ihr dann ganz in ihrem sinne sein
ja das ist in unserem sinne die frage
ist warum ist es bis jetzt nicht
geschehen warum hat man so lange
gewartet und es ist wie gesagt ein
absolutes probleme in heimen das
personalmangel herrscht und das konnte
man bislang nicht lösen
auch die versprechen von herrn spahn die
ja zum beispiel gegeben hat dass man bis
ende januar sämtliche alten und
pflegeheim auch die alternativen pflege
unterkünfte dass man die durchgeimpft
haben möchte wir also schön sagt wird
nicht gelingen also auch dieses
versprechen hat man gebrochen und wird
man auch nicht erreichen können also das
sind die dinge die man der
bundesregierung hier ankreiden muss und
damit das ganze land in mithaftung zu
nehmen das ist wirklich skandalös in
sachsen kam er zu einem zweiten tor
vorerst in sachsen kam eher die regel
derzeit gestern beschlossen wurde schon
seit mitte dezember in kraft nämlich
dass man das haus nur noch aus triftigen
gründen verlassen darf jetzt soll das in
ganz deutschland ab der inzidenz von 200
kommen so eine aussetzung von
grundrechten haben sie noch ende
november als ich zu dir das mal
gefährdend für die demokratie bezeichnet
wie bezeichnen sie das jetzt mir absolut
ist es ja auch wirklich ihre juristische
als zweifelhaft was hier gerade
beschlossen wurde was gestern auch
beschlossen wurde nochmal noch dazu
verschärft sowie die vorgehen ja derzeit
in sachsen sind dass man sagt das ja nur
noch mit getroffen werden kann sich mit
einem einer person aus einem haushalt
das bedeutet also wenn oma opa zu besuch
kommen will muss man feuer auslösen wer
kommen darf entweder die oma oder europa
also das sind alles dinge die man
wirklich auch rechtlich sagen muss die
sind nicht haltbar bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher
und hier werden grund und
freiheitsrechte rücklicht ausgehebelt
und hier versucht man wirklich mit
maßnahmen auch die bevölkerung
einzuschüchtern
die ich nicht gut finde die wir nicht
als auf die gut finden wo wir wirklich
uns fragen müssen in welchen rechtsstaat
wie eigentlich noch leben und diese
maßnahmen ob die wirklich auch die
wirkung erzielen die bezweifle ich sehr
stark
die saubere sachen wie würden sie denn
dann die inzidenz runter bekommen oder
sagen sie wir brauchen die instituts gar
nicht runter bekommen dann nur mit
risikogruppen schützen wird ja
wahrscheinlich nicht reichen gerade wenn
neues mutiertes virus aus großbritannien
weiter in deutschland sich um sich
greifen würde
ja zumindest mit maßnahmen die die
bevölkerung erstens akzeptiert und auch
vor allen dingen versteht also man muss
auch die dinge die man erklären
darstellen damit die bevölkerung auch
diese mit mit durchführen kann
bislang habe man gesehen dass die bühne
des die bundesbürger doch weitestgehend
diesen regelungen gefolgt sind dass sie
sich auch sehr vorbildlich gehalten hat
aber er muss man sich auch erst mal
bedanken bevor man weitere schärfere
maßnahmen ergreifen will wir müssen aber
auch ein stückweit ehrlich sein und
sagen dass wir mit diesem virus leben
werden und auch die nächsten monate und
vielleicht sogar jahre leben werden wir
wissen auch nicht ob die impfung die
versprochenen die jetzt durchgeführt
werden sollen ob die auch die wirkung
erzielen wie die bereitschaft der
impfung sein werden in der bevölkerung
wissen wir auch nicht also auch da muss
man ehrlich sein und wir müssen im
prinzip auch den leuten sagen wenn die
inzidenz zahlen ende januar nicht
runtergehen was sollen wir dann tun
wollen wir den doktor bis ende februar
bis ende märz weiter durchführen also es
halte ich wirklich auch wirtschaftlich
war wirklich stark gefährden
wir müssen davon ausgehen und das soll
sagen wir sagen ja die zahlen dass uns
dieser london aktuell 1,5 bis 3
milliarden euro pro woche kostet wir
müssen auch den bürgern erklären wer
soll das eigentlich bezahlen soll dass
die zukünftige generation leisten also
diese fragen wurden ja alle nicht
geklärt ich denke da muss man auch
ehrlich mit der bevölkerung umgehen herr
kuba das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz
das ich sagen einerseits wir müssen mit
diesen maßnahmen leben andererseits
sagen sie sind unverhältnismäßig also
kinder nicht mehr in kitas schulen nicht
mehr in schulen cafés restaurants
fitness studios geschlossen halten sie
das alles für unverhältnismäßig ist
macht das aus ihrer sicht keinen sinn
ich habe ich gesagt dass wir diesen
maßnahmen leben müssen aber die
einrichtungen die sich bislang an die
hygiene vorschriften auch gehalten haben
diese idee auch mächtige investitionen
geleistet haben um im prinzip weiter zu
öffnen der mittelstand aber auch die
gastronomie und hotelgewerbe
die müssen sofort wieder öffnen dürfen
auch kind geht das und schulen müssen
geöffnet werden denn wenn die kinder
nicht in die schule gehen können und
auch nicht im kindergarten wo sollen
dann die eltern arbeiten gehen können
also es gibt für viele familien geht es
ja auch um existenzen auch um lohn und
brot und das müssen wir doch erklären
also wir werden mit diesen maßnahmen die
jetzt getroffen werden unseren
volkswirtschaftlichen schaden wirklich
eminenz hochfahren und das halte ich
wirklich für mittlerweile
ja gefährden für die ganze gesellschaft
das heißt ich verstehe sie richtig sie
würden dafür plädieren cafés und
restaurants wieder zu öffnen weil die
eben auch vorkehrungen geschlossen haben
und aus ihrer sicht zweitens könnten
auch die schulen wieder öffnen
absolut und es gibt ja bislang auch
keine belege dafür dass infektionen in
den restaurants die sich an die hygiene
vorschriften gehalten habe stattgefunden
haben also deswegen sagen wir auch ein
star der mittelstand muss hier wieder
hochgefahren werden können
auch grad was gastronomie und hotellerie
angeht braucht der einzelhandel der
massiv darunter leidet hier stehen
wirklich hunderttausende arbeitsplätze
auf der kippe
wir haben jetzt schon 500.000 mehr
arbeitslose als im vorjahresmonat also
das sind die zahlen die uns erschrecken
und wo man mittlerweile sehen dass die
kosten und auch vor allem der schaden
außerhalb coronas wesentlich höher sein
wird
die nekropole bundessprecher der
alternative für deutschland hier heute
morgen im tagesgespräch bei phoenix
fielen dankt ihnen für das gespräch
sehr gerne